hi my name is Kevin and I'm a unique and
special snowflake I work at blizzard
entertainment great place for a
snowflake blizzard we make games no let
me clarify that we obsess over games
Megan games is awesome but it's also
really hard I know what you're thinking
how hard can it be really hard so you
want to make games of course you do we
want to help we want to help you so bad
that we are willing to give you our own
stuff completely free [ __ ] this is
something we've been doing for a while
now orkut 123 starcraft one starcraft 2
look some people call the mod tools we
like to call them genre-defining
opportunity makers or just change the
face of the gaming industry tools short
let's be crystal clear these are not
some second-rate tools here these are
the exact same tools that we use to make
our own game all we need is a beautiful
snowflake willing to run them you're
beautiful be confident this is our
editor did you know that this comes
totally packed with 14,000 513 custom
art models and 20 2758 textures ready to
rock your personal creations maybe you
would like to know that this will be the
leading cause of highly successful
careers in triple-a gaming companies did
you know that its potential your
potential has yet to be tapped
somebody use this thing you invent the
pixel we want you to have it Blizzard
just made access to the arcade
completely free that means that not only
are the millions of voracious gamers
that log into the platform every month
primed and ready to consume your
developmental delicacies but now anyone
that you can convince to have even a
remote interest in your game as a
straight path to access it and no cost
to them you see I'm not the only unique
and special snowflake you are and you
deserve to be appreciated as such and
the game you're going to make deserves
to be played big games it's hard you can
do this you got everything you need